what's up everyone we are currently at
the MIT Media Lab with Beckett Dunning
Becca Dunning is a part of learn to
teach teach to learn which is a great
way for young kids to learn new
technologies and then teach them to
other younger kids over time so when
when did this I mean I'm holding I'm
holding a micro bit right now and this
is one of the many things that you do
teach young kids to learn and then pass
down that that knowledge on how to use
it - yeah this this is awesome okay so
when did how did this how did this sort
of idea of birth it was like 20 years
ago and then how did you get involved
why is this important to you and then
we'll kind of go into like what these
things are
so I originally started with learn to
teach program when I was in high school
my senior year in high school and I came
in as a new youth teacher so basically
the way the program works is you have
news teachers returning youth teachers
and college mentors and the idea is
basically that as people go through they
gain information around how to do that
basically technology like digital
fabrication and manufacturing and also
it's called learn to teach teach to
learn in that the actual learning and
the teaching is what sort of promotes
the passage of learning so as part of
the program people learn all these
technologies and how to use them but at
the same time they're thinking about
lessons or thinking about individual
projects and then they're taking that
information and they're taking it out to
different community centers and
organizations around the city to share
that knowledge with younger students in
the hopes that they can perhaps rate
that process this happens at the high
school level like the entry point so as
a freshman you get to play with these
tools and by the time you're like a
junior you're teaching freshman so it's
actually happening it happens as young
as 14 some students 14 to 15 and they
start at that point I start a little bit
later as compared to most people would
come into the program but they start
then and would be a youth teacher up
until their senior year of high school
after their senior year when they
continued on to higher education they
would then if to come back they come
back as a college mentor and many people
tend to come back and then basically
they would become the people who are
helping to facilitate and help
to share and help develop the next
generation of learning and what are you
guys at now with 20 years of this under
your belt are you in a like a couple
hundred high schools or do you know how
many you're in now I personally can't
speak for the whole group yeah in that
I've only so I started there in 2010 and
I know that there are many people who
have gone through the program and have
continued on into pursuing engineering
computer science and higher education
and I know that they service many
community centers throughout the city
and basically as part of that summer
program it's they will go out to maybe
four or five different immunity centers
at any given time and basically run
comfortable lessons with very young
students all the way up to sometimes
high school students nice and this is
your community's here in Boston yeah yes
so the Southern Technology Center is
where a lot of this lunch teach program
happens and as part of that program they
come to MIT Media Lab to do some of
their learning both to see the space to
become inspired and also further their
learning and in other times the selling
Technology Center was the original Fab
Lab so it's basically two buildings
there's the learning component of it and
there's also the fabrication lab people
can come in and at a very young age be
exposed to things like 3d printing laser
cutting vinyl cutting PCB manufacturing
so things that normally you wouldn't get
to see until a college level yeah and
then that unlocks their potential for so
much more once their minds been expanded
to those new areas so you're been doing
this eight years now yeah okay and so
this technology here is the micro bit so
this is similar to an Arduino and so
it's programmable to do you gave me a
pretty good example there as these Wi-Fi
light bulbs and so normally we pay
whatever 50 bucks for one of these but
actually all you needs a light bulb and
a programming a chip to be able to
listicles a lot of things you can do a
lot of things we'd normally pay
for you can make with all different
kinds of electronic components we them
discrete lectrons are with more of these
microcontroller based systems and it's
sort of in exposing people to things
like the micro bit it sort of brought us
to horizon to us to what you could do
with programming and with hardware so as
opposed to going out and say I'm gonna
spend a hundred dollars in our system
and spent fifty dollars in the system
you could say not only can I build it
for much cheaper but I can continue to
do that if someone had a great idea as
an example you could turn that into your
own product someday so it sort of gives
you the ability to take what you could
learn in terms of programming and give
it a physical application and then after
you get to learn these skills you get to
apply them to other areas like you were
describing further not just to
potentially decrease the own your own
cost of goods but also your learning
about how the black box works then
you're taking the skills that you learn
from that and applying it to the further
things that you create especially for
young kids in in high school that's
really important this reminds me a lot
of FIRST Robotics actually where they
engineer and design robots to complete
out on playing fields this is also you
know being except that you know what's
really cool about this is that they're
also teaching other kids because when
you also teach then you're firing and
wiring a second or a third or even a
fifth or twelfth time over and over
these connections in your mind in order
to be able to retain them for longer
periods of time and and practice them
put them to skills it's all about
thinking not just about how you think
about things but how someone else would
think about and how you'd explain to
them in a way which would both teach
them but also sort of get it to solidify
and to further their knowledge so the
more you learn it's like if you learn
something and you never can apply it and
you can never tell someone it you can
never you can only do it yourself what
really is the point of that learning
sort of about the sharing of knowledge
and the perpetuation of learning I love
that yeah yeah that's so aligned with
our values and why we have this channel
as well it's uh perpetuate all this
knowledge that's been coming from so
many different industries you bring up a
really good point which is that it takes
a certain special person to learn how to
teach different people because different
people have different learning styles
there's one thing about the program is
to think that anyone has the capacity
to learn or to do anything so not to
necessarily just say well as you say I'm
a great person at teaching I can convey
all of these things but not just put
yourself sort of in your own little tree
house if you will like to say that
anyone could learn those skills and to
show someone both by mentorship and
example and through guided activities
hey you can do this too and one day to
make everyone at that same level so they
sort of the cyclical process yeah and
then there's also this unlocking you
know in the kids eyes as they get to get
to do something themselves that works
and that they got to do they'd built it
they did it and then that goes AHA I can
do it and I had this guidance from other
people like you along the way that
helped me or even kids that are only a
year to my senior instead of a whole
fledged adult so then it's even more
like oh I can teach in one year or two
years when I've learned it and this
experience is like a very important part
to that near-peer yes so near peer you
actually learned from someone like say
like myself I'm 26 right now and
basically like if I was to be teaching
someone who would say 12 I wouldn't be
as close in ability to relate as someone
who would say hey in middle school high
and high school and they would be able
to say in a way interface better with
that age group so it's sort of saying
well not only is this knowledge that you
can gain but I'm someone who's of your
equal age range who's sort of in the
same structure in situation as you who
got this so when you see someone that's
like really near peer to you you can
easily convey information and people
just retain that a lot more easily and
get inspired by it more because they can
see themselves easily in their shoes in
a year - doing the same thing versus if
it was 25 you would be like ah man 12
years my senior I thought yeah Wow
the near peer that's really the first
time that that's sink in to be as
impactful as it is now in me is that you
really need that to be a close person of
age to you as well so that you can get
further inspired by it
okay what about other thoughts about
learn to teach teach to learn that you
want to show I would say the people who
run winch teach teach learn program are
very passionate about what they do I
originally dr. Mel King took the South
and Technology Center as his emeritus
office and had opened it up as a center
which could give back to the youth and
could make more people inspired and
definitely be good to meet them dr. King
and dr. Susan clinic at some points who
are always selling Technology Center
always keeping things running also
Edward baffi who has been taking an
active role in helping to get things
running how coordinating helped to
basically get everything together in our
most recent iterations of the program so
I just think there's a lot of people
there's a lot of work that goes into
doing it but at the end of the day it's
all about just really making an impact
on these young people's that and helping
them to not only learn themselves but
helping them to basically create the
scaffolding and pathways for them to do
the same for others so well said yeah
that's and and I just I always think
about their actualization once they've
gained these skills and added them to
their tool belt because they were
exposed to them through programs like
yours that's when they're actually able
to fully become realized in the world
and they're able to you know delve into
different areas because they have
different tools you know and all this
kind of good stuff maybe we can sit down
with one of them maybe we can do that we
leave Monday afternoon so maybe we could
do it before then let's see but if not
next time we're here or SF will
coordinate we'll see what we can do
alright that was so much fun like to
thank you so much it's been a stroke
that was super fun
appreciate it a lot